Hello internet.
The UK had an election that we should talk about, because after the debates,
voting and adding the ballot papers the result looked like this:
While the division in parliament came to look like this:
This is a little unrepresentative and by a little not mean I absolutely do not.
Red received 30% of the votes and 36% of the seats, which is sort of true but the rest
looks awful. Orange got 8% and only one eighth of seats while Geels got 5%
doubled and purple earned 13% and received payment.
Meanwhile, Blauws increased 37% of the votes to 51% of the seats in parliament. And that
profit is even greater since that 51% of the seats you 100% of the
gives control.
How could this happen?
In the UK, national elections are not really national. They are a lot of local elections.
The UK is divided into districts, each of which elects a MP (MP)
to represent them. This division between local / national is where the problems begin.
Imagine a parliament with only three districts and you quickly see how such a system is not always
corresponds to the people. Some people think that's fine, "it's all about
winning local elections "they will say." Each MP represents its own district "
And although the deviation in this example is exaggerated, the same problem happens in the real one
election and the same argument is given, but there are still two problems
the land of reality.
1) Few citizens know who their MP is, they only know which party they voted for
- which party they want as a representative at the national level. And pretend
it is a local election is rather unfair. In practice it is an election for how
the country is governed, not who becomes the representative of a small part of it.
And even if that was the case
2) the districts are even worse in representing their citizens than the parliament.
Please excuse this Excel sheet containing nerd for a moment.
The difference between what a party earns from votes and what a party earns from seats
is the deviation in misrepresentation.
If we calculate all deviations for all parties and add them all up then we can say that the parliament
47% of misrepresentation. That sounds bad but is a utopian
rainbow of diversity compared to the local election for local elections have
only 1 winner. Of the 650 districts, 647 have a higher deviation than
the parliament. These are the only three who don't have that and they are very unusual for having
from so many voters from just one party in a district.
most places look like The Wrekin, which is right in the middle, with a hundred and one points difference.
But the winning candidate did not get a majority here. What does that mean
more than half of the districts have elected their MPs with a minority.
The worst is Belfast South, at the bottom of the list. Hilariously unrepresentative. Less than
a quarter of voters speak for the entire district in parliament. This is
the lowest percentage ever with which an MP has been elected.
So if people argue that the elections are a set of local elections, then: 1 people behave
do not adhere to it and 2 it is an even better argument that the elections are not good because on
at this level they are worse.
These local elections are unrepresentative because of the terrible "first past the post"
system-- which I often complain about and so will not complain about - look at
the video - because it only 'works' if voters are limited to 2 choices
Voting for a party other than the largest makes it more likely that the largest party with a minority wins.
Exactly what happened.
That residents continue to vote for smaller parties, even though this goes against their strategic interests
shows that people want different representation. But this makes it the most misrepresented
Parliament in the history of the UK.
People who are happy with the result will say that the system works.
Naturally, their team has won.
But the government is not a sport where a winner must be designated. It is a system
to make rules that everyone must follow. So we need a system where everyone agrees
that the process is fair, even if the results are not what they want.
If you are in favor of a system that disadvantages people that you do not like, and puts people ahead
that you like, then you are not really someone who supports representative democracy. You are more it
kind that supports some form of dictatorship light, where a small group of people
makes the rules for everyone.
But as it is now, and when people indicate more and more what they want in elections, this will lead to a bad system
making people uninterested, or worse: angry and JEMIG IK SNAP
NOT WHY.
This is recoverable. There are much better ways the UK can vote. Here are 2 options that even
local representatives.
And restoring voting is important, because this is a kind of government legitimacy score
and this score has been getting worse for some time, and will get worse unless this is fundamentally wrong
is being changed.